voici nina et farceur et à leur allure
athlétique on peut deviner que ces
chevaux de trait ne sont pas venus ici
pour gambader dans les prés au contraire
ils ont été missionnés pendant deux
jours par l'entreprise et ne disent
leurs objectifs tractée huit poteaux en
béton jusqu'à une zone de dépôt ou en
camion prendra le relais les chevaux
donc on encolure avec un collier qui les
préserve de tout de tout effort de toute
difficulté et en fait on met un on met
des poteaux béton sur un attelage vont
rechercher les poteaux béton et les
ramènent jusqu'à un endroit de stockage
temporaire avant qu'on les achemine vers
un centre de recyclage conforme vu qu'il
ya eu là on peut le voir le il ya eu
beaucoup d'eau il y à des déserts à
certains endroits il ya peu de passage à
d'autres et donc bah là à utiliser les
chevaux qui sont très maniable et qui
eux peuvent marcher facilement et en
plus on a pas de risque de renversement
on a pas de risque d'enlisement aînés 10
a fait appel à sabots sur terre une
entreprise normande dirigé par louise
brieuc qui intervient dans toute la
france depuis 2010 9 cette passionnée
d'équitation dresse elle même ses
chevaux qui lui obéissent au doigt et à
l'oeil quand je tire comme ça c'est
gauche voilà ma jument et me donne la
tête et quand je fais des plus des
petits lacs ou cetc droite puis
passionné de chevaux depuis mes 10 ans
et j'ai fait des études j'ai trente
trois ans et j'ai découvert la traction
animale à mes 27 ans par là je cherchais
à travailler avec avec les chevaux dans
mais pas me concentrer uniquement sur
eux faire faire quelque chose avec eux
pratique et écologique cette méthode
ancienne fait son grand retour pour des
questions essentiellement
environnementales les chevaux il ya
moins de nuisances sonores il ya moins
de nuisances en termes de co2
effectivement l'empreinte carbone est
maîtrisé mais également un enjeu de
biodiversité parce que si on était en
effet intervenir des engins soient plus
créé des ornières dans ce terrain très
boueux très boueux très marécageux
première à déployer cette pratique dans
les yvelines est né dix espère que
d'autres projets comme celui-ci
émergeront